i don't know how much you're familiar
with joe rogan
he does bring up dmt quite a bit it's
almost a meme
uh it is a name have you ever uh
have you ever tried dmt uh
i mean he i think he talks about this
experience of um
having met other entities um
and uh they were mocking him i think if
i remember the experience correctly
like laughing at him and saying f-u-f-u
or something like that
i'm maybe misremembering this but but
there's a general mockery
and uh the the what he learned from that
experience is that he shouldn't take
himself too seriously
so it's the dissolution of the ego and
so on like what do you think about
uh that experience and maybe if you have
more general things about the
joe's infatuation with dmt and if dmt
has
that important role to play in
popular culture in general i'm
definitely familiar with it i remember
telling you all flying that when i first
the first time i
learned who joe rogan was probably 15
years ago
and i came up on a clip and i realized
there's another person in the world
who's into both
dmt and brazilian jiu jitsu and i think
both those worlds have grown
dramatically since and it's probably not
such a special club these days so
he definitely it you know got onto my
radar screen
quickly you you were into both before it
was cool
right i mean you know this is all
relative because there's people that
were you know before the late
90s and early 2000s that were into it to
say you know you're a johnny come lately
but
but yeah compared to where we're at now
but yet
one of the things i always found
fascinating by by joe's
you know um telling of his experience
experiences i think is that they
resemble very much
terence mckenna's experiences with dmt
and joe has talked very much about
terence mckenna
and his experiences if i had to guess i
would guess that probably just having
heard terence mckenna talk about his
experiences
that joe's that that influenced the
coloring
yeah it's funny it's funny how that
works because i mean that's why mckenna
hasn't
i mean poets and uh great orders
give us the words to then like start to
describe our experiences because
our words are limited our language is
limited and it's always nice to get some
kind of nice poetry into the mix
to allow us to put words to it right and
he
but i also see some elements that that
that seem to relate to joe's psychology
get just
from what i've seen in him you know from
hours of watching him on his podcast is
that
you know he's a self-critical guy
yes and i think with always this
positive ben i'm always struck
being a behavioral pharmacologist and he
no one else really says it about
cannabis i'll get back to the dnt thing
about
he likes the kind of the paranoid side
of things he's like that's you radically
examining yourself yeah
it's like that's not just a bad thing
that's you need to like look hard at
yourself
and something's making you uncomfortable
like dig into that and like that's his
it's sort of along the lines of goggins
with exercise and it's like
yeah like things learning experiences
aren't supposed to be easy
like take advantage of these
uncomfortable experience it's why we
call in our research
in a safe context with psychedelics
they're not bad trips they're
challenging experiences
yes so yeah it's fascinating just a tiny
tangent
it's always cool for me to hear him talk
about
marijuana like weed as the paranoia the
anxiety or whatever
that you experience as actually the
the the fuel for the experience like i
think he talks about
uh smoking weed when he's writing that's
inspiring to me because
then you can't possibly have a bad
experience
i'm a huge fan of that like every
experience is good
um right which is very goggins yeah it's
very good yeah
is it bad okay all right great you know
well see goggins is one side of that he
wants it bad
i like he wants the experience to be
challenging always
but i mean like both are good like
the the the few times of uh taking
mushrooms the experience was uh
like everything was beautiful there's
zero challenging uh aspect to it it was
just like the world is beautiful and it
gave me this deep appreciation of the
world
i would say so like that's amazing but
also
ones that challenge you are also amazing
like all the times i drink vodka but
uh but that's another let's not so back
to dmt
um yeah and joe's treating you know
cannabis as a psychedelic which is
something that i'd say like not a lot of
a lot of people treat it more like xanax
or like beer
yes you know or vodka um but he's really
trying to
delve into those the miners it's been
called a minor psychedelic so with dmt
you know as you brought up it's like the
the entity's mocking him
and it's like you're not i mean this
reminds me of him you know
him describing his like you know writing
his
or just just his entire method of
of comedy it's like watch the tape of
yourself
you know don't just ignore it like
that's where i screwed up
that's where i need to do better this
like sort of radical self-examination
which i think our society is kind of
getting away from because like you know
all the children win
trophies type of thing you know it's
like no no don't go overboard but like
recognize when you've messed up yes and
so like
that's a big part of the psychedelic
experience like people come
out sometimes saying my god i need to
say sorry to my mom
yeah you know like it's so obvious
like or so whatever you know
interpersonal
issue or like my god i don't i'm not
pulling enough weight
around the house and helping my wife and
you know you know these things that are
just obvious to them
the self-criticism that can be a very
positive thing if you act on it
you